in the last video we saw a method of
figuring out what the basis for column
space is and we use these exact examples
where if this was matrix a i just took
it and i put it in reduced row echelon
form and i figured out which of these
columns in my reduced row echelon form
of a are pivot columns and it turned out
to be the first one the second one and
the fourth one and then the method is
you say look the corresponding columns
in a so the first one the second one the
fourth one form my basis for my column
space and since they form the basis and
you want to know that if you want to
know the dimension of your basis of your
column space which is also called the
rank you just say well there's three in
there so it has a rank of one two three
in this video i want to discuss a little
bit about why this worked why were we
able to just take the corresponding
columns why did linear independence of
these three guys imply linear
independence of these three guys why was
the fact that i can represent these guys
this guy right here is a linear
combination of these three or this guy
is a linear combination of these three
why does that imply that i can
well that can construct this guy as a
linear combination of my vases vectors
so the first thing i think we that
wasn't too much of a stretch of the
imagination in the last video was the
idea
that these pivot vectors are linearly
independent so r1
r2
and r4 and everything i'm doing i'm kind
of applying to the special case just so
that it's easier to understand but it
should be generalizable in fact it
definitely is generalizable that all of
the pin pivot columns in reduced row
echelon form are linearly independent
and that's because the very nature of
reduced row echelon form is that you are
the only pivot column that has a one in
that respective row so the only way to
construct it is with that vector you
can't construct it with the other pivot
columns because they're all going to
have 0 in that row and when i say it's
linearly independent i'm just saying the
set of pivot columns so let me say this
in general the set
of pivot columns
pivot columns
for any
for
any
reduced row echelon form matrix
is linearly independent
and it's just a very straightforward
argument because there each column is
going to have one in a very unique place
all the other row all of the other
pivot columns we're gonna have a zero in
that same place and so you can't take
any linear combination to get to that
one because zero times anything minus or
plus zero times anything can never be
equal to 1. so i think you can accept
that now that means that the solution to
the solution to
r1
r c1 times r1 plus c2
times r2 plus let me say c4 times r for
the solution to this equation because
these guys are linearly independent we
know that this only has one solution and
that's c1 c2 and c4 is equal to 0.
that's the only solution to that so
another way we could say it is if we
write r times some vector x
some vector well i'll just write it
times this particular x where i write it
and 0
is equal to 0. so this will be some
special member of your null space it's a
particular solution to the equation
this is equal to
one two three four zeros because we have
four rows here
now if this if we just expand this out
if we just multiply one times c1 plus 0
times c2 minus
1 times
c minus 1 times 0 plus 4 times 0 you'll
get
or actually let me a better way to
explain it this multiplication right
here can be written as and we've seen
this multiple times
c1
times r1
plus c2
times r2
plus 0 times r3 so we can just ignore
that term plus c4
c4 times r4
plus 0 times plus 0 times r5 that's r5
right there all of that equal to 0. so
the only solution to this because we
know that these three columns are
linearly independent or the set of just
those three columns those three pivot
columns are linearly independent the
only solution here is all of these equal
to zero that's exactly what i said right
up here so the only solution here where
if these two are zero is that these guys
also all have to equal zero if i already
constrained these two now the one thing
that we've done over and over again we
know that the solution set of this
equation the solution set of
rx
rx is equal to 0 is the same as the
solution set of ax is equal to 0. now
how do we know that or what do i mean
well the solution set of this is just
the null space
the solution set
is just the null space of r it's all of
the x that satisfied this equation and
we know that that is equal to the null
space of a because r is just a in
reduced row echelon form so this is the
null space of a is all of the x's that
satisfy this equation
now the only the only version of this
that satisfied this equation was when c1
c2 and c4 are equal to zero so that
tells us that the only version of
this
the only version of this c1
c2
0
c4 0
that satisfies
this equation or this equation is when
c1 c2 and c4 is equal to zero or another
way of saying that if this is
this is vector a1 a2 a4 right here if
you multiply this out you get
c1 let me do it over here
you get let me do it in
blue you get c1
times a1
plus c2
times a2
and then 0 times a3 plus c4 times a4
plus c4
times a4
is equal to 0. now these guys are going
to be linearly independent if and only
if the only solution to this
equation
is they all equal to zero well we know
that the only solution to this is that
they all equal zero because anything
that's a solution to this is a solution
to this and the only solution to this
was if i if i
go ahead and i constrain these two terms
to be equal to zero the only solution to
this is all of these c's have to be zero
so likewise if i if i constrain these to
be zero the only solution to this is
that c1 c2 and c4 have to be zero so
those guys have to be zero which imply
which imply that these three vectors a1
a2 and a4
so that implies that the set a1
a2
and a4
are linear and linearly independent so
we're halfway there we've shown that
look because the pivot columns here are
linearly independent we can show and
they have the same solution set the the
null space of the reduced row echelon
form is the same as the null space of
our original matrix we were able to show
that the only solution to c1 times this
plus c2 times this plus c4 times this is
when all the constants are zero which
shows that these three vectors or set of
those three vectors are definitely
linearly independent now the next thing
to prove that they are a basis is to
show that look all of the other vectors
all of the other column vectors can be
represented as multiples of these three
guys and i realize just for the sake of
just for the sake of clarity or maybe
not boring you too much i'll do that in
the next video so in this one we saw
that look if these if the pivot columns
are linearly independent they always are
all pivot columns by definition are
linearly independent or the set of pivot
columns are always linearly independent
when you take away the non-pivot columns
then the corresponding columns in your
original vector are also linearly
independent and the next one will show
that these three guys also span your
column space